um people are desperate for clarity
as i'm sure you'll appreciate are you
any closer to telling them as well
whether they can travel internationally
from may the 17th we're definitely
closer
um we'll say that before may the 17th
which is the earliest possible date if
you remember the prime minister's
roadmap and we'll be able to say uh
whether we can resume on the 17th of may
uh but what we've got today is a
framework for doing that so this traffic
light system you've been talking about
red amber green
and in the green category we'll try to
make it as affordable
as possible to travel but taking
abundance of
of caution as we go because we don't
want to throw away
all the good work of these lockdowns and
people coming forward for vaccines by
picking up variants of concern or
anything else so
it's a cautious move but at least it
provides that framework for people
uh what would you say to those who who
might think the cost will be
prohibitive for people to travel say for
a family of
four with a test costing about 120
pounds that's nearly 500 pounds
on top of the cost of a holiday if they
have to
carry out pcr tests yeah and costs are
definitely a concern it's one of the
factors um this year and we have to
accept we're still going through a
global
pandemic you know actually i think we
kind of forget in the uk because
we've had such a successful rollout of
the vaccine and the most of any
major economy but actually in the rest
of the world
uh actually this thing is raging and uh
there's a big
third wave and so we do have to be
cautious and i'm afraid that does
involve having to have some tests
and the like but i am undertaking today
to drive down
the costs of those tests and
looking at some innovative innovative
things we could do uh for example
whether we can
help provide the uh lateral flow test
that people need to take
before they depart the country that
they're in to return to the
uk and also drive down the costs of the
the test when they get home if it's in
the green category where it's just a
single test
so we're trying to make it as as
practical as possible i think everybody
accepts
there are more more problems to resolve
than there would have been if
coronavirus wasn't around but
we're trying to do everything we can to
help what about the cost that people
might have to pay if they have to
quarantine when they get
home in in a hotel at their own expense
yes well i think you know as far as red
countries red list countries
are concerned and we've got i think 39
of them at the moment
um for the most part people aren't
traveling from those countries and
at the moment of course um is the case
that people are going to those
quarantine um hotels
and they'll be factoring that in before
they decide to travel from those
locations i don't think they'll be
summer holiday locations that's you know
of course because of the the quarantine
nature of them
uh i think what people will be looking
at is the green list in particular and
thinking well perhaps
those are the countries to go to um and
what we try to do
which is an innovation on last year is
introduce what we're calling a green
watch list
so that if we have concerns and these
are likely this year to be
concerns over different variants uh
coming about
and then we can kind of indicate that
flag that up to people
and then they have a little bit of
notice rather than what we saw
uh last year which were things changing
very quickly which i experienced myself
as we had to change um spain uh off the
uh
of the corridor at that time so we're
trying to find ways to
improve the situation everyone accepts
there's more risk involved in traveling
during corona virus but for the first
time there's a framework
and for the first time people may be
starting to think about not just
international holidays but you know the
number of people who have families
abroad and haven't seen them for
months on end and of course getting
business restarted as well so those are
really
important aspects of this how often will
you be
reviewing the list very regularly
um so that the list itself will be under
a constant review because we have to
respond to
uh the coronavirus itself and we all
know how this works it can move pretty
quick um but more fundamentally we'll
also review
on three specific dates at the end of
june
july and beginning of october we'll
actually review
the system itself in other words what
you have to do if you're in a green
amber and uh red to see whether we can
uh lessen
uh any of the different criteria so
we'll be reviewing it constantly
uh but the important thing is to have
this kind of framework that people can
say
okay um if we do want to go away or if i
want to
visit a loved one you know one figure
which is absolutely amazing i was
looking the
the office of national statistics say
that over a third
of all children born in the uk have at
least one parent
who was born outside of the uk so we
have this enormous international
network probably more than almost any
other country
and people of course want to see their
families just as we do domestically
as we get to these different stages of
the unlock including next monday
um what sort of help will be put in
place if people find that the situation
changes as you described while they're
abroad
and the the country that they've
traveled to has one status when they
arrived
but another when they're they're about
to leave
well first of all the green watch list
is designed to
help people to get some forward guidance
now i can't guarantee
that that will always be um you know
absolutely 100
available we may have to make very quick
decisions as as we had to last year but
on
balance in general if you have for
example
a variation uh in the coronavirus you
usually have a
at least a couple of weeks whilst you're
sequencing that to see whether
it's actually a variation of concern
where the mutation is
more significant and so that will give
people a period of time to potentially
know so that's the first thing we'll
have should have a bit more notice this
year
and then secondly of course you've got
the the consulates and assistance around
the world from
the foreign commonwealth development
office which uh which people are able to
turn to for help and advice and that's
very well established globally
so what's the official advice from the
government at the moment
should people be booking foreign
holidays because uh
not so long ago the advice was was not
tim and perhaps
book a holiday within the uk
well my advice today would be again sort
of moving on from from where we were
before
i'm not telling people that they
shouldn't book some holidays now it's
the first time i've been able to say
that for
many months but i think everybody doing
it understands there are
risks with coronavirus and of course
actually i think people would want to be
clear about which countries are going to
be in the different traffic light
system and people predominantly of
course be looking to book
uh in a green country um so there's only
two or three weeks to wait before we
publish that list itself but yes
tentative progress
for the first time people can start to
think about
visiting loved ones abroad or perhaps a
summer
holiday but we're doing it very very
cautiously because we don't want to see
any return of coronavirus in this
country i just want to ask you about
northern ireland we've seen the use of
water cannon on the streets of belfast
for the first time
in six years um what do you think the uk
government should be doing
to bring about peace well very
concerning and i just can actually say i
don't there's no
role for violence um to resolve these
issues
whatsoever and particularly against the
police service of of northern ireland
who are just working to try to you know
keep things calm
last night the prime minister spoke to
the t-shock
all the different parties in the
northern ireland assembly have issued
sort of a joint
statement calling for uh calm calling
for an end to the
uh violence i understand from the
secretary of state for northern ireland
that things were
a little bit calmer yesterday compared
with the night before
we need to make sure that people are
talking and resolving
whatever concerns they have but not
through violence
um and just on the the lobbying route
with the greenzel uh
story the treasury has you know released
text messages from rishi sunak's private
phone
uh to the prime minister david cameron
um
they do show that the lengths that the
former prime minister was going to
to in order to to make his case for
green cell
do you think he's behaved reputably well
he's a private citizen
uh he's not within the couple of years
that where the the rules apply after you
leave public office and he's free to do
what he likes and the most important
thing about this whole story
uh is of course um green sill the the
company in
uh in the news there didn't get whatever
it was asking for so that the whole
system has worked
uh just as it should do and um it's been
judged fairly afraid over time does that
speak to though privileged access to
the heart of of government that that
other companies wouldn't have privy to
well i mean companies are actually very
adept at um making sure that they can
get their messages
across and it's very common for uh
ministers to receive messages i know
what the chancellor did
is exactly what i would do all ministers
would do uh
correctly which is just to ping that
message on to officials who then deal
with it in the normal way it doesn't
really matter how you
end up speaking to government and
government has to speak to industry all
the time it's a it's a factor of
of needing to uh needing to communicate
it doesn't really matter how it comes in
the fact of the matter is um the result
is you know whatever the correctness
you can't change those facts of life he
was a previous prime minister but as
you've seen
it hasn't changed the outcome and that
should give people i think quite a lot
of reassurance about our system do you
think david cameron should speak out
just to put this to bed now
entirely up to him uh you know i say he
actually predicted
uh you know it's a lobbying as a as a
problem
many many years ago i think 10 years ago
but it's entirely up to
up to him uh he is entitled as a private
citizen to
do whatever he likes i think the most
important thing is that the
upshot the outcome of this is exactly as
it would have been had it been
anyone or any company and i'm afraid in
this case green sill
didn't get what they were after in any
case